et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
pierre faire son bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député de paris délégué général
adjoint de la république en marche merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
détention pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est bonjour stéphane
bonjour avec qui dirige le bureau
parisien du quotidien ouest france on va
commencer par cette lettre pierre person
cette lettre qui fait polémique de
lettres écrites par emmanuel macron pour
dédouaner son bras droit alexis colère
soupçonné de prise illégale d'intérêts
quand il était à bercy ce qu'emmanuel
macro enfreint la séparation des
pouvoirs et tenter de faire pression sur
la justice
eh bien je vais vous répondre par là
même c'est à dire que je considère en
tant que jeune parlementaire que c'est
par un garde la séparation des pouvoirs
et c'est pas à moi aujourd'hui en tant
que parlementaire député de m'exprimer
sur sur une affaire en cours
ensuite un propos peut-être plus
générale et un propos plus personnel
plus général alexis colère c'est un con
citoyens comme les autres
il n'a pas plus de droits mais il a pas
moins droit à l'époque et bien emmanuel
macron était son employeur je ne vois
pas pourquoi emmanuel macron ne pouvait
pas justifier notamment des changes qui
l'avait tenu avec son salarié son
collaborateur président de la république
pose pas de problème maintenant ça
voudrait dire qu'en fait alexis colère
ne peut pas se défendre comme tout
citoyen parce que emmanuel macron est
aujourd'hui président de la république à
l'époque emmanuel macron n'étais pas
président de la république et ministre
d'économie et alexis colère était son
collaborateur
deuxième chose plus personnel c'est que
je connais alexis colère maintenant
depuis quatre ans c'est un fervent
serviteur de l'état et je le redis parce
que il n'ya pas beaucoup aujourd'hui
d'hommes qui ont la république chevillée
au corps comme cela c'est quelqu'un qui
a et sa probité
c'est quelqu'un qui a toute ma confiance
et pour lequel je trouve que le procès
aujourd'hui qui lui est fait un procès
terriblement injuste parce que il doit
avoir la possibilité de se défendre et
ça ne doit pas être un procès qui doit
être médiatisé tel qu'on le voit à
l'heure actuelle on est déjà en train de
parler d'un ferr colère c'est une
affaire où c'est une tempête dans un
verre d'eau moi je pense que c'est une
tempête dans un verre d'eau après je
vous le redis je suis parlementaire
je n'ai pas accès à l'instruction ce
n'est pas à moi d'en commenter mais je
trouve qu'en effet les faits qui sont
rapportés et qui sont un peu édulcoré
représente plus une tempête dans un
verre d'eau que finalement une véritable
affaire allez on va parler de l'après
crise
emmanuel macron qui consultent pour
préparer cet après crise
zulte les groupes politiques qui
consultent aussi l'ancien président de
la république est ce que vous vous
attendez un tournant changement de cap
pour la fin de ce quinquennat
j'étais venu sur votre plateau il ya il
ya maintenant trois mois à quatre ou
cinq jours je crois du confinement
on peut pas en effet dire que il la
situation est la même
je vais vous me posiez d'ailleurs la
question de savoir si l'état allait être
au rendez vous je pense que l'état a été
là quand on lâche 500 milliards pour
soutenir à la fois les individus et les
entreprises
c'est bien que ont fait face à la
situation qui est une situation qui
était quasiment inédite
donc oui il y aura un après un tournant
mais il ya un tournant qui est aussi lié
finalement à la crise à la crise que
nous avons vécue à la crise qui va
arriver parce que on voit bien le nombre
de plans sociaux qui est en train de
s'accumuler en france et donc il faut
alors que nous soyons à la hauteur après
avoir travaillé sur la crise sanitaire
que nous soyons hauteur face à la crise
sociale la crise économique qui en train
d'intervenir et social qu'a manqué en
début de quinquennat je pense pas je
pense que sur le social il ya beaucoup
on a fait beaucoup sur le social sûr que
je pense qu'on a accompagné les
individus on a remis en branle la
formation on a travaillé à ce que
l'école soit finalement un lieu où on
puisse mieux lutter contre les
déterminismes donc on a fait beaucoup
sur sociale après c'est sûr que
aujourd'hui la crise qui va venir va
impacter massivement notamment les plus
précaires et je ne connais pas une crise
qui donne plus de justice avant et enfin
après a posteriori finalement de son
impact est donc il va falloir que nous
soyons au rendez vous pour aider les
individus aider les français à faire
face à la situation qui va venir
alors vous employer le mot tournant le
président a pu dû cul par le nouvelle
étape ses opposants disent est un acte
iii c koi de bons éléments de langage
comme on appelle la nouvelle phase je
sais pas vous savez moi je suis pas dans
éléments de langage pense que d'ailleurs
les français n'ont que faire des
éléments de langage ils verront les
actes et ils verront les fesses que nous
prenons les actes ce sera quoi en fait
parce que les actes ils ont déjà ils ont
déjà commencé et je suis dit enfin si à
l'époque il ya encore quatre mois je
vous avais dit sur le plateau que l'état
serait au rendez vous avec 500 milliards
pour aider les entreprises et les
individus qu'une grande partie des
salariés français seraient pendant trois
mois en chômage partiel aidé et donc par
par l'état vous m'aurez regardé en me
disant que j'étais un extraterrestre et
d'ailleurs je pense que moi même je
n'aurais pas pu vous dire ça sur c'est
un tel plateau donc
j-ch l'état est au rendez vous les
français ont vu factuellement les
entreprises ont été aidées
on les a aidés dans leur trésorerie les
individus ont été accompagnés pour pour
pouvoir vivre c'est de confinement et
nous allons continuer c'est d'ailleurs
l'objectif des consultations du
président de la république qui a ceci
tout le monde pour pouvoir mettre en
branle finalement un dispositif qui
accompagne pendant les deux prochaines
années
eh bien tous les français dans l'après
crise
mais par la force des choses il y aura
des changements radicaux qui vont qui
vont sortir de ces consultations et de
la nouvelle étape ou de la phase qui
s'ouvre dans la collecte de toutes
façons pour pour une forme de radicalité
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui nous a nomique
sociale assure institutionnels ces
institutionnels s'est assise nationale
mais je pense que de toute façon nous
devons être dans une pratique de la
radicalité nous avons été élus sur cette
promesse là de changer les choses mais c
est ce que ces policiers à 2 ans à 2 à
deux ans de la présidentielle c'est
possible de tout remettre à plat et de
tout changer alors qu'on on est on est
très très courte échéance par rapport à
7,7 ce thème la gestion réaliser ça j'ai
été élu pendant cinq ans et quand on me
dit qu'en fait il nous reste un an
effectifs parce que nous aurions un
temps ensuite de campagne présidentielle
je ne le prends pas en tant qu à la fois
en tant que jeune en tant que jeune élu
mais en tant que français moi je
comprends pas dire que nous avons encore
deux ans pour lequel nous sommes en
responsabilité pendant ces deux ans nous
devons faire en sorte finalement est
bien d'aider les français à faire face
notamment à la crise et à continuer à
porter les réformes qui nous paraissent
justes j'ai donc on va pas aujourd'hui
elle ajouté en se disant est ce que on
devrait le faire ce qu'on devrait pas
faire ce qu'on devrait attendre deux ans
nous raconte en baisse de rythme il y
aura un an
il faut continuer c'est la promesse
d'ailleurs intrinsèque finalement macro
nisme sûr je pense que si on n'est pas
en mouvement on meurt et donc il faut
absolument continuer à porter les
réformes qui ont fait aussi la réussite
vous démarriez à la présidentielle sur
ce que vous avez des radicalités sur le
plan institutionnel concrètement ça veut
dire quoi c'est pas à moi de l'inventer
je pense que d'ailleurs c'est ça doit
être le fruit de concertations de
concertation avec cette chambre le sénat
ça doit être concertation avec les élus
locaux mais je pense en effet que notre
modèle institutionnel et démocratique
doit être revue parce que dans le coin
bien la défiance aujourd'hui de nos
concitoyens à l'égard finalement notre
vie politique notre vidéo
c'est pas à moi de faire des
propositions ici sur ce plateau mais
c'est quand vous dites radicalité sur le
plan national vous avez forcément des
propositions en tête mais j'ai des
propositions et je les garde pour moi et
je les ferai notamment à l'endroit à la
fois de ma majorité et du président la
république mais je pense que en effet la
vie démocratique doit être réinventé
dans notre prix est ce que lorsque c'est
ça qui fait qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
autant d'absents sionisme ça vous a fait
aujourd'hui une défiance du politique
vous avez une absence de confiance dans
le personnel politique c'est parce que
aussi les règles telles qu'elles sont
faites aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas
mais ça veut dire quoi changer de régime
finie la vème république
non messieurs je vous le dis je sais pas
vous annoncer aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
qu'il faudrait faire si cela et c'est
d'ailleurs vous voyez bien quand vous
bougez un indicateur et bien c'est aussi
le fonctionnement de nos institutions
qui est complètement bouleversée donc
c'est un sujet extrêmement sérieux mais
on peut pas en effet ce stade se
satisfaire d'un statut quo ça vaut pour
l'institutionnel ça vaut pour le social
ça vaut aussi pour l'économie est ce que
ça commence par un nouveau gouvernement
réinventer pour reprendre un mode
emmanuel macron et c'est à dire aux
structures et de manière totalement
originale très différente de ce qui a
existé jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais je
réalise en deçà pareil c'est pas à moi
de faire des annonces de l'exécutif je
suis ni président de la république il
premier ministre moi je suis
parlementaire et je suis là vous avez
les oreilles qui traînent vous entendez
un petit peu ce qu'ils soient et j'ai
très bien compris que que aujourd'hui
mondialement il y avait il y avait un
intérêt pour pour le pour la chose après
c'est pas à moi de faire de faire le
casting c'est pas à moi de répondre
d'ailleurs savoir qu'il sera mieux à la
place etc
je pense que c'est le président
république et le premier ministre qui
font leur équipe et qui ensuite
impulsent la politique gouvernementale
olivier ferrand annoncé hier une
enveloppe de 6 milliards pour les
soignants pour notamment pour
revaloriser leur salaire ça fait
plusieurs mois qu'ils manifestent ces
soignants il a fallu cette crise
sanitaire pour que le gouvernement les
entende enfin ils ont été entendus à
plusieurs reprises peut-être pas
suffisamment je pense d'ailleurs vous me
posiez la question de savoir s'il y
allait avoir plus de besoins pour
l'hôpital juste avant le confinement il
ya eu plus de besoins pour les hôpitaux
il ya eu plus de considération à mon
avis même pas simplement politique de
nos concitoyens pour le personnel
soignant je pense que cette crise a
révélé plusieurs choses et donc il va
falloir être au rendez vous des
promesses que nous avons fait
parce que ne pas avoir débloqué
une enveloppe avant mais parce que
j'avais avoir accepté s'il ya beaucoup
de services publiera en france qui
nécessitent aussi d'être accompagné
d'être transformés peut-être d'être
mieux financer mais il ya des choix qui
sont faits et quand j'entends parfois
une partie de l'opposition qui dit c'est
là ma chronique qui a tué le service
public hospitalier
j'ai en marche sur la tête sur nous
sommes arrivés trois ans pouvoir la
situation qui était la nôtre elle
perdurait depuis déjà bien longtemps
aujourd'hui on va continuer à améliorer
à la fois le fonctionnement spitalier
est aussi revaloriser les personnels en
personnel soignant qui font un job
extrêmement extrêmement important notre
pays et donc il faut être au rendez vous
des promesses
après je ne vais pas venir vous soldée
comme ça d'un coup d'un seul ce qui fait
que pendant 15 ans la situation s'est
dégradée
du côté de l'assurance chômage avec le
contexte qui s'annonce la crise à venir
est ce que est ce qu'il y aurait pas
intérêt à revoir ou réajuster cette
réforme qui pourrait avoir un effet
délétère sur les gens qui vont se
retrouver massivement au chômage
c'est derrière nous c'est d'ailleurs ce
que c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous avons
fait ce cirque le constat initial
c'était que nous n'atteignons pas le
plein emploi mais en tout cas il y avait
une reprise économique c'est qu'elle est
gavé de nouveau c'est plus la
perspective de nouveaux travailleurs qui
rentrait sur le marché du travail et qu'
il y avait un flux qui était un peu plus
tendue qu'avant avec une baisse du
chômage et donc on a décidé de réadapter
les modalités en a fait de l'assurance
chômage
c'était la réforme portée il y à il ya
quelques mois mais là le contexte change
le contexte a changé c'est pour ça que
nous avons décidé finalement de
suspendre cette réforme est d'attendre
avant sa mise en oeuvre
parce qu'on ne sait pas en effet ce que
sera le marché du travail dans quatre
mois moi je ne peux pas le dire je pense
que les économistes peinent à le dire et
donc il faut anticiper mais il faut
aussi savoir et bien travaillé sur le
temps présent et en l'occurrence cette
réforme
elle devra à mon avis s'adapter aussi
aux conditions au du travail en france
et c'est pour ça que nous l'avons
suspendue pour le moment et la réforme
des retraites parce que les clés ce qui
va se passer je vous disais sur la
réforme des retraites
et ça c'est mon avis c'est mon avis plus
personnelles même s'il n'existe pas en
politique notamment quand vous êtes
numéro deux d'un mouvement mais je dire
il ya aucune crise qui crée de la
justice est le constat que nous avons
fait est que j'ai fait est que beaucoup
de mes de mes collègues ont fait
lorsqu'ils ont porté notamment cette
promesse de la réforme des retraites
pendant la campagne présidentielle
c'est que le système a été injuste je ne
considère pas que après la prise du coc
vide le système soit plus juste est-ce
qu'il est plus juste pour les femmes qui
sont moins payés finalement que les
hommes ce qu'ils sont est-ce que plus
juste pour les agriculteurs non je ne
pense pas donc je pense qu'il faudra que
nous tirions aussi les conséquences de
cette injustice dans le cadre de
retraite et que nous continuons aussi
oui peut-être pas de la même façon
peut-être pas avec la même méthode
mais en tout cas il faut que en effet
nous considérions que la situation
n'était pas là mais je ne sais pas si
c'est la même réforme en tant qu' en
tant que tel dans toutes les
dispositions mais en tout cas le
principe la genèse même de cette réforme
est là elle n'a pas changé parce que les
injustices qui était latente avant le
confinement
aujourd'hui sont toujours aussi présents
un petit peu changé c'est que cette
réforme systémique elle était possible
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de problème d'
équilibre du système c'est plus le cas
du tout aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est encore possible de
faire une mesure systémique sans
s'attaquer à une réforme financière de
ce système faudra tout remettre à plat
après je vous le redis mois les règles
comptables à la fois je considère que en
effet il ne faut pas être dépensiers en
outre mesure c'est à dire qu' il faut
faire attention à notre déficit et à
notre dette par fais pas partie de ceux
qui considèrent que de toute façon nous
pouvons tout dépenser 100 videmment
évidemment regarder l'accumulation de
ces dettes qui pèsera notamment sur les
générations futures
les gens qui aujourd'hui commence à
rentrer sur le marché du travail la
réforme seront donc on était pas obligé
de toucher aux paramètres de la réforme
est ce que là il va falloir augmenter
moi je de départ est ce qu'à un moment
il va falloir résoudre cette question
financière
il faudra peut-être y travailler dans
les années dans les années à venir mais
le principe de l'arema le principe de la
réforme que nous avons promis aux
français qui a été validé par l'élection
présidentielle c'était un régime
finalement qui donne plus d'égalité et
plus de droits c'était pas un régime
paramétrique c'était pas un équilibre
budgétaire s'était pas une réforme est
une réforme de justice sociale et cette
justice sociale qui permettait de dire à
nos concitoyens à 1 euro cotisé 1 euro
égale les mêmes droits pour tous pour
redonner à la fois confiance aux
nouveaux entrants qui rentrent
aujourd'hui dans le marché du travail
qui ne croient plus à la retraite sir
que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne croit
plus au mécanisme de retraite est aussi
pourrait bien s'attaquer aux inégalités
à la fois sociale professionnelle qui
font qu'aujourd'hui à travail égal
vous n'avez pas la même retraite mais
c'est quoi la nouvelle stratégie sur les
retraites c'est de s'attaquer par
exemple à des inégalités par morceau je
pense notamment aux retraites plancher
pour les agriculteurs qui seront qui sue
qui sera le le texte de loi sera sera
voté au sénat lundi prochain est ce que
vous allez comme ça procéder à des
ajustements en attendant la grande
réforme
je peux vous aviez suspendu par le passé
est acceptable aujourd'hui pour revenir
sur ça d'ailleurs ce que je vous disais
je veux pas faire de politique
politicienne
enfin toutes nos oppositions droite et
gauche confondues nous ont dit que la
réforme des retraites que nous prévoyons
s'était d'ailleurs en décembre était une
réforme injuste
aujourd'hui j'ai grand plaisir de voir
notamment le président chassaigne qui
est un député communiste se saisir de
dispositions que nous avions promis aux
français et qui considèrent que donc en
fait finalement ce sont des dispositions
qui sont juste pas soumises à la loi et
date de décembre 2016 et ses lacets
gouvernement mais c'est fait barrage
l'année dernière mais c'était prévu sur
la revalorisation des retraites
agricoles c'est ce que nous avions prévu
dans toutes les interventions dans la
grande réforme dernier assure bien sûr
donc je me félicite finalement
qu'aujourd'hui une partie de
l'opposition soutiennent eu un boum la
réforme des retraites que nous nous
proposions à l'époque je pense que en
effet il va lui falloir aller plus loin
il va falloir aller travailler
finalement à combler les inégalités
professionnelles de certaines catégories
et notamment aussi des femmes qui dans
notre pays est bien sont moins protégés
lorsqu elles lorsqu'elles partent à la
retraite l'audition de vous laver est ce
que vous l'avez suivi déjà et qu'elle
est le cas quelle est l'impression
générale que vous a donné le professeur
out dans cette audition je les ai suivis
partiellement à vrai dire avec mes
collaborateurs fière de mon point de vue
je veux dire et c'est ce que je vais
essayer de ne pas faire ce matin je
pense que on ne doit pas faire de la
politique avec la science c'est ce qu'il
est en train de faire en tout cas la
science ne serait plus la science elle
se perdrait si elle faisait de la
politique je ne sais pas si didier
raoult le fait de la politique
en tout cas didier raoul est un
spécialiste
c'est quelqu'un qui est reconnue dans
son domaine pour ses compétences
scientifiques
après je pense que je me garderai bien
faire de la politique avec avec le sujet
parce que je pense que on l'a bien vu
d'ailleurs monsieur raoul on a été
confronté lui-même il y à des situations
qui ont évolué et à un instant t en
janvier certaines choses ont été
annoncées d'ailleurs par lui-même qui
ont étaient invérifiables suite après et
lui-même s'est contredit plusieurs fois
donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui un scientifique dans notre
pays qui détient l'unique vérité il ya
des scientifiques et d'ailleurs je vois
bien ce qui est encore en train de
monter sûr qu' il ya un scientifique qui
prend toute la lumière au détriment
d'ailleurs de centaines de milliers
d'autres qui font un travail qui ont
parfois des thèses qui sont différentes
et je pense que les tests de monsieur
raoul ne veulent pas plus finalement que
les thèses aujourd'hui d'autres
épidémiologistes et donc je ferai très
attention là dessus et nous sommes dans
le cadre d'une commission denquête c'est
bien normal c'est un outil
institutionnel
je pense qu'il faut il faut le défendre
je pense que c'est un outil qui est
l'audition d'hier pour vous elle éclaire
le débat public où on nous ressort elle
éclaire le débat elle éclaire le débat
public mais vous dire que ensuite il
n'ya pas certaines interrogations qui
naissent après 7,7 audition en tout cas
de mon point de vue moi je me suis posé
plusieurs questions en regardant 7,7
cette audition le rôle de l'opposition
et aussi parfois même les et comment
dirais-je ce kiss kiss qui était sous
jacent finalement derrière les
interventions de monsieur roule mais en
tout cas ce que je veux dire c'est que
il
à la fois ses compétences scientifiques
mais moi je ferais très attention de ne
pas faire de la politique avec la
science alors a terminé en parlant des
municipales en mode sur paris d'abord
interné débat ce soir entre les
candidates est ce que le match est plié
dont le match n'est jamais plié avant
finalement d'avoir dépouillé le dernier
le dernier bulletin de vote vous croyez
encore la victoire de la république en
marche à paris on a une compagne qui
était difficile je vous dis pas tu pas
le contraire après je pense que en effet
il ya des endroits où nous pouvons
gagner
il ya certains arrondissements où nous
pouvons faire des scores après je vous
dis encore été la mairie ça va être un
challenge c'est un siège comme toute
élection mais croyant encore vraiment eu
moi je souhaite pas faire des pronostics
notamment vous savez je suis numéro
d'automne parti c'est pas à moi de venir
dire avant le scrutin si on va gagner ou
si on va perdre
c'est d'ailleurs d'une part aux
électeurs ce serait à mon avis très
déplacé vis-à-vis des électeurs et puis
ça serait très déplacé vis-à-vis de nos
candidats voyez on a une élection qui
était une élection compliquée elle se
terminera dimanche soir on l'a bien vu à
la fois parce que comme nous sommes un
parti au pouvoir
c'est toujours plus compliqué et nous
avons en plus cette double difficulté
d'être un jeune parti gérant 65 de
gaulle et s'est pas réveillé avec une
majorité municipale
donc est ce pour autant ça n'a pas
empêché de continuer à gouverner la
république en marche et elle est en
train de construire cette majorité
municipale ce oui je pense gagner
affirme que vous aurez vous dit me
conseiller et lui vraiment je pense que
nous aurons en effet cet objectif de
rempli mais pourtant c'est pas
simplement ça l'objectif
le problème c'est que vous n'aurez
aucune grande ville non mais nous aurons
des des acteurs à la fois de la société
civile qui sont en responsabilité dans
les mairies nous aurons à la fois des
gens qui s'engagent et en 2017
on souhaite une président de la
république et qui ont décidé que leurs
engagements devaient se matérialiser par
par amanda savez il ya un an françois
baroin disait il y aura plein de mairie
en france qui n'auront pas de mer eh
bien je pense qu'aujourd'hui cette
théorie est invalidée nous avons eu
comme un engouement pour pour les
municipales nous avons eu un engouement
sur en termes d'engagement et moi je
souhaite remercier même au delà
simplement des troupes de la république
en marge des candidats de la république
arrache tout ceux qui se sont investis
pour faire vivre aujourd'hui la
démocratie dans les villes et dans les
villages la république en marche n'a pas
échoué à s'implanter localement
je pense qu'elle a pris la construire à
mon avis ce qui est la base elle a
commencé à s'implanter
les premières pierres finalement de ce
que serait et bien la gouvernance locale
elle y participera la google est la
république en marche sera présent dans
les conseils municipaux inscrivez dans
un dans un processus de construction de
sur le temps long oui le temps mais sur
l'autre sauf que ça va être le temps
très long parce qu est ce qui vous
manque c'est vous un moment vous pensiez
quand même pouvoir prendre paris lyon
encore une fois par strasbourg et encore
c'est pas fait vous n'aurez aucune
grande ville et le souci c'est que pour
le dynamique se met en place beaucoup
plus lentement que ce coût sur les
élections au népal et je pense que la
république en marche a toujours eu un
mot c'était modestie et humilité
on l'a vu voilà vous êtes pas trompés
non et je pense que c'est plutôt
vérifier et je pense qu'il faut
d'ailleurs toujours être humble avant
même d'ailleurs que le scrutin soit joué
donc bien entendu que c'est un scrutin
qui est compliqué pour un parti au
pouvoir pour un jeune parti mais notre
objectif c'est finalement d'implanter
notre jeune forces politiques dans le
paysage politique et je pense que nous
avons pu se met finalement les premières
graines qui nous permettront ensuite à
terme bien d'avoir des acteurs
politiques locaux qui pourquoi pas dans
les années futures prendront des mérites
est ce qu'après ces municipales il va
quand même y avoir des questions qui
vont se poser au sein du parti de la
république en marche est ce que vous
allez devoir vous remettre en question
et de quelle manière on doit toujours se
remettre en question vous savez c'est
pas que simplement les municipales quand
vous êtes un acteur politique que vous
avez été élu face à marine le pen en
2017 que vous avez mon âge vous devez
toujours vous remettre en question parce
que sinon finalement vous correspondez à
la fois pas la promesse qui était la
promesse macro nist et puis ensuite vous
considère les français considèrent que
vous êtes en décalage
donc oui bien entendu mais là clairement
il ya quelque chose qui fonctionne pas
dans votre mouvement non je ne le pense
pas je pense qu'on est dans une
situation qui est particulière je pense
qu'il faudra travailler pour que la
majorité soit plus solide parce que nous
avons aujourd'hui une majorité qui est
diverse qui est riche en sensibilité et
moi je pense qu aujourd'hui nous nous
devons travailler à la construction de
cette majorité
après il y aura par cette assemblée
nationale je sais pas simplement sapin
simplement à l'assemblée nationale je
suis dit j'ai une âme en avant
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'offres partisane
c'est à dire nous avons agir nous avons
le modem est à la république en marche
nous continuons à travailler finalement
à faire un blog
pour continuer la recomposition
politique de notre pays et donc il
faudra très certainement sur le cadre
partisan continuer à accroître
finalement cette dynamique après vous
dire que il doit y avoir des procès qui
sont faits pour ou contre les résultats
des municipales
c'est pas du tout à mon avis ce qu'il
faut que nous fassions nous sommes pas
dans une logique de division nous sommes
dans une logique finalement de
construction en réalité vos résultats
modestes aux municipales vont vous
obliger à travailler vos alliances avec
vos partenaires naturels et arraisonné
beaucoup plus en terme de bloc de la
majorité présidentielle que en rythmant
en termes de république en marche seul
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
d'aider le président de la république a
porté le projet qui était le nôtre en
2017 qui se voit aujourd'hui complétée
notamment après la crise et l'aider pour
2022 voilà donc c'est pas simplement la
république en marche
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est d'aider le
président de la république a porté les
réformes qui aident nos concitoyens donc
c'est pour ça je pense d'ailleurs que
nos concitoyens n'ont que faire
finalement de nos blocs partisans ce qui
nous intéresse c'est finalement leur
quotidien et moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que nous puissions travailler à
cela et merci beaucoup merci pierre
façon d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
merci stéphane